sabemos que un trinomio cuadrado
perfecto es un polinomio de tres
términos el cual resulta de elevar al
cuadrado un binomio por la atención el
trinomio 20 x 25 + 4 x al cuadrado igual
a 0 es un ejemplo pero como sabemos que
es perfecto si el trinomio que te
presentan no está ordenado como es este
caso lo primero es ordenarlo esto quiere
decir acomodar sus elementos de mayor a
menor
de acuerdo al exponente y al final el
término independiente que es el que no
tiene literal
entonces ya ordenado nos queda 4x al
cuadrado más 20 x 25 igual a 0
una vez ordenado solo tienes que fijarte
muy bien que el primer y tercer término
sean el cuadrado de algún número es
decir que el trinomio tenga por ejemplo
un 14 9 16 25 36 49 64 81 etcétera
identificando esto tenemos que sacar la
raíz cuadrada de cada uno de ellos las
multiplicamos entre sí y el resultado
que obtenemos lo multiplicamos por 2
para comprobar el término de enmedio
mira la raíz cuadrada de 4x cuadrada es
2 x de 25 5 multiplicamos 2 por 5 y el
resultado es 10 esto por 2 resulta 20
excelente
como 20 es el doble de las dos raíces y
las raíces del primer y tercer término
fueron exactas
tenemos un trinomio cuadrado perfecto
que factor izado lo expresamos así 2x +
5 al cuadrado
un tipo observa que exponente está
elevada la literal del trinomio cuando
son cuadrados por lo general encontrarás
exponentes par como 2 468
ahora qué pasa cuando tenemos trinomios
que no son cuadrados perfectos o sea
trinomios imperfectos cómo lo resolvemos
hagámoslo poco a poco y así te darás
cuenta que es más fácil de lo que crees
tenemos el siguiente trinomio x al
cuadrado más 11 x 30 igual a 0
revisemos que esté ordenado primero
tenemos el exponente más grande que es 2
después el exponente 1 que aunque no lo
vemos s su valor y por último el término
independiente listo comprendamos
entonces de manera muy sencilla porque
este trinomio no es perfecto como el
anterior
el primer término que es x al cuadrado
si tiene raíces exacta la cual es equis
pero el tercer término o sea el 30 no
cuenta con raíces exacta ya que la raíz
de 30 es 5.47 muy bien este simple hecho
lo hace imperfecto una raíz exacta y la
otra no sabiendo esto como lo resolvemos
una forma para hacerlo es encontrar dos
números que al sumarse el resultado sea
11 y al multiplicarse resulte 30 no te
espantes verás que es súper sencillo
escribamos en una tablita todos los
factores o sea los números que pueden
dividir al 30 de manera exacta lo
haremos así fíjate muy bien 30 y de este
lado 115 y 2 10 y 3 y por último
y 5 acomodamos cada pareja para que
multiplicada nos dé 30 o sea que cumpla
con la primera condición y así sólo
buscaremos la pareja que sumada nos dé
11 entonces 31 es 31 estamos muy lejos
del once
15 23 17 no nos sirve 10 313 tampoco por
ultimo 65 resulta 11 cuando ésta es la
pareja que nos funciona porque 6 por 5
es igual a 36 más 5 es igual a 11 casi
sin darnos cuenta hemos factor izado
nuestro trinomio imperfecto sólo nos
falta obtener la raíz del primer término
la raíz de x al cuadrado es x muy bien
así que todo esto lo expresamos de la
siguiente manera x 6 x x 5 igual a 0
vemos otra forma de factorizar un
trinomio imperfecto tenemos el siguiente
ejemplo 3 x al cuadrado más 27 x más 60
igual a cero
cuando se te presente en el primer
término un coeficiente distinto a 1 es
decir que haya algún número acompañando
a la literal como en este caso lo
primero que hay que hacer es tratar de
eliminar ese número como dividiendo
todos los elementos del trinomio entre
ese número o sea el número que divide al
primer término es el mismo que divide al
segundo y al tercero veamos el 3 lo
dividimos entre 3 y obtenemos x al
cuadrado 27 x entre 3
el resultado es 9 x y el 60 entre 3
obtenemos 20 excelente hemos eliminado
de nuestro trinomio el primer
coeficiente por lo que ahora sólo
tenemos que encontrar la pareja de
números que sumados nos dé 9 y
multiplicados nos dé 20 como en el caso
anterior
hacemos nuestra tablita de todos los
factores 21 10 y 25 y 4 podemos notar
que 5 y 4 es la pareja que nos funciona
porque 5 4 es 9 y 5 por 4 obtenemos 20
perfecto como estos son los dos factores
que nos funcionan los acomodamos como
una multiplicación de binomios y lo
expresamos así x + 5 x x 4 igual a 0
estas fueron sólo algunas maneras de
resolver trinomios te invito a que
descubras más